i just got to say too uh they take pickpocketing
to a whole new level they are like magicians
in this room they are there are scenes where
you're like you couldn't have hidden a swipe
in there there's literally like feet apart
and there's no arms distance that could have
accounted for that they'll be standing like
this far apart some character on the walk away
and then it is magical oh
my god they stole my points
what's happening reject nation greg
and john chartered their way to the
movie theaters over at cinemark to watch the
movie uncharted the way to see this movie would be
in the theaters with its massive action scenes
especially in the last half of this film
cinemark thank you for inviting us and also
you guys can have a private watch party for
this movie when we were coming prior it was 20
people now you can bring up to 30 people and
watching with our buddies this way being able to
talk amongst ourselves laugh me telling them to
shut up stop chewing your food so loud was
perfect i am the perfect person to go have
a private watch party with as i am abusive to
all my family and friends but you know what it
makes for a better viewing experience in the end
now let's talk about our feelings for uncharted
all right guys so let's get this out of the
way i played the first three uncharted games
i don't remember them at all i remember like
tiny bits and pieces so when it comes to oh my
god did they ruin my beloved video game i don't
know maybe it seems likely to be totally honest
games probably felt a little bit more like
an authentic movie too long story short with
this film tom holland plays nathan drake a
young version a little boy in an old man's
body or something is going on here it's benjamin
button and he teams up with mark wahlberg's sully
to go to traverse the world looking for treasure
and it's one of those you know swashbuckling
tomb raider mummy indiana jones spy wannabe types
of films you know what i'll say like after the
first trailer we were pretty honest about our
feelings i was like that didn't look too great
but here's the honest-to-god truth the movie
was better than i expected it to be but also
way more boring than i expected it to be at the
same time yeah it's like it's charmingly bad
and endearingly boring so let's talk about some
positives first tom holland was not bad he's very
affable he's enjoyable to watch oh crap oh crap
there's a lot of those adr lines that are like
what does nathan drake say when he's in the middle
of a fight oh crap oh [ __ ] he was really fun
uh he's tom holland plus parkour and bartending
skills like in all sincerity it took me a while to
really buy him in the role not because i was like
is this accurate to the way i remember the video
game it's a very specific type of like manly role
well it requires like a harrison ford type almost
it requires somebody with that rugged edge who's
still charming and fun christopher pratt like
chris pratt yeah exactly let's get owen from
jurassic park in here yeah tom holland has this
very clean every man very good-natured type of
charm so it does feel like the movie is very much
trying to get him to a point where you're like
no this dude's edgy i did like him in the action
this is really doing a lot of his own stunts and
it is great it's like i think we always heard
that with spider-man to actually be like that's
really tom holland moving around like that that's
actually really impressive mark wahlberg look
i he is not anything like sully from the video
game you know what he is like is mark wahlberg
he's like mark wahlberg and he does a good job
at that mark wahlberg impression he's very
very good as that and daddy a brother for me i
and i think him and uh tom holland you know
their chemistry kind of flip-flops from time
to time it's just kind of odd in the first
half of this movie i would say i think in
the last half is when it started to really
mesh together a lot more in the first half
i was just kind of like i should be having
fun but this movie feels a little soulless
last flat that's probably a more accurate word
than soulless it was felt like it was striving for
spirit it just felt like hollywood
screenplay you know really
and then somebody finally picked it up and went
hey can we can we graph some uncharted motifs onto
this and get some celebrities here we go we've got
a property let's do it a lot of the the pacing and
a lot of the the jokes and just the energy about
it like you said just feels a little bit flat and
unexciting despite how much globe trotting and
exposition of just being like a historical detail
my god just so much of it i just gotta say too uh
they take pickpocketing to a whole new level they
are like magicians in this room they are there are
scenes where you're like you couldn't have hidden
a swipe in there there's literally like feet
apart and there's no arms distance that could
have accounted for that they'll be standing like
this far apart some character on the walk away
yeah there are a lot of very strange logical
decisions about physics and uh people's ability
to pickpocket the efficacy of electronics in
varying difficult uh weather situations antonio
manderis is wasted and goofy here's the thing
though the last half has has some of the most
uncharted vibe that i think you would want in
terms of just the actual movie and in terms of
the action scenes like the action scenes there's
two big set pieces in this film that get just
bonkers they're they're ridiculous everyone in
our theater was just laughing i wasn't i was happy
genuinely i was like i don't care how freaking
stupid this is this is so fun it got really fun in
those moments and this movie has two post credits
scenes count it two they really want that sequel
those post credits scenes felt a little bit more
like chart of the game than most of the movies
it's like mortal kombat in that sense where you're
like oh maybe the sequel will be uncharted the
whole movie spends its time building up to these
things where you're like oh we're finally gonna
get to something that really resembles uncharted
at it and it almost kinda does i'm just like
the movie's fine it's just uh it falls a little
flat full of cliches it's really nothing special
it doesn't really help with like can video games
be good adaptations go watch tomb raider with
alicia vikander i prefer that one i mean that at
least actually kind of resembles what the game is
is kind of supposed to be like you see like i
barely even remember the uncharted game and i'm
just watching this movie on its own and just
on its own it's like it's fine that's like the
whole vibe i have like that's fine if this was
on tv i'd be like it's a little boring but it's
a little entertaining too as much as there is
to gripe about it i was always kind of smiling
and chuckling for one reason or another uh so yeah
it's it's weird it's like i can't really say it's
a good movie you need to go see it but if you want
to have fun you you actually you might in spite of
everything that's actually happening on screen i
would say that there's a couple of action scenes
in here that are worth watching the theaters alone
i mean that sincerely but yeah overall with the
ratings i'd give it like uh you know of uh i don't
care um yeah just you know make up your own god
if you're gonna watch it watch it all right i
find it fairly ironic that a video game that
borrowed so much from movies and was lauded for
being especially cinematic made for a movie that
doesn't feel like it bothered to be very like
cinematic or borrow from the movies that the game
was actually borrowing from itself we're gonna
have these two people have been watching us this
whole time awkwardly just trying to figure out how
to formulate their opinions no just get them on
here to switch the mics greg mentioned this film
fell a little bit flat on the jokes i thought this
film was unintentionally funny in many moments
like there were some serious moments where we
were balls out laughing so i mean there were
some moments i really enjoyed but overall falls
out laughing yes i don't think i've ever heard
yes we were balls out laughing yes yes exactly
yes we were come to cinemark you'll see that's
where ball's out laughing happens at cinemark
yeah this film can sometimes uh be very mildly
entertaining but in a very unintentionally funny
way aaron what did you think had all the
testicular fortitude of a 40 year old man
edging to find his uh freedom and
passion again i like tom holland
i like mark wahlberg but i feel like oh man this
is like the definition of obligatory i played
all the uncharted games so uh i am something of
a semi expert and yeah it was it was not good
how did you really feel uh it's uh it's not
horrible it's perfectly acceptable tnt cable fall
asleep kind of movie this movie is it exists you
know and if you're going to fall asleep somewhere
do it a cinemark they got the best seats there
you have it folks there you have it come here
go to the market and take a nap take a nap very
comfortable seating conditioning they'll turn
the volume up real loud they have officially
revoked our passes to go watch the batman